all right so how do you get your first
1000
subscribers in this video i'm going to
be sharing some strategies that i
haven't really talked about anywhere
else
and really four powerful principles to
get you to 1 000
subscribers quickly and beyond and so
uh get ready and if we're just meeting
my name is sean cannell
and i'm the co-author of the number one
best-selling youtube strategy book
youtube secrets and uh my passion is
helping people build
their influence and their income with
online video
and youtube so smash the like button and
let's dive right into this content
if you're new to the coffee with kennel
show
for the next 10 minutes or so i'm gonna
break down these four tips i got a bonus
tip as well
to get to 1 000 subscribers and then i'm
going to bring
you on the show so if you want to join
the show to talk about
social media youtube online business
life
and really how to go further faster and
pivot your plan during this crazy time
then we'll be getting to that soon but
let's dive straight into
the content and um i'm excited because
this is actually some training that you
at first
may have think you've heard before but
then we're really gonna get into some
details
that i've never really talked about four
powerful ways to attract your first
1000 subscribers and foundationally
it's gonna come down to wait for it and
don't leave for it
consistency consistency but i got four
different dimensions of consistency
that most creators are missing
most people are only focusing on
frequency of content but there's three
other ones
actually four other ones that people
don't actually see beneath
the surface but foundationally let me
know how consistent have you been on
youtube
are you posting at least one video a
week are you posting more than that tell
me in the comments section
uh wherever you're watching this but
here's something that the rock said the
highest paid act
the wwf wwe star
uh the dwayne rock johnson success isn't
always about greatness
it's about consistency consistent hard
work
leads to success and then greatness will
come so here's the thing with
consistency if you want to be taken
seriously on youtube you've got to be
consistent if you want to build trust on
youtube
you have to be consistent you either
keep your promises
or don't make them because c is the
foundation of trust
consistency will build your credibility
consistency
will grow your subscribers success is
not magical nor mysterious
success is the natural consequence of
consistent
consistently applying the basic funnels
and so first off if you want to reach 1
000 subscribers
faster you've got to be posting
consistent content
and we're going to go into deeper
principles you're like oh i've heard
this before though bro
i know post no we're going to go deeper
down the rabbit hole alice
buckle your seat belt but it starts
foundationally
with posting consistent content and i
have some stories to share with you
from some of the people that are part of
our video ranking academy
but this is jennifer so she does the
sewing report
she quit her job she's doing youtube
full time she actually has a couple
different channels
but it's uh it's been incredible to see
her journey making from affiliate
marketing
but she's posting consistent content not
just for a week not just for a month
but for years now she's been posting
consistently
this is mary and we recently had her on
what's called the vra show
her channel's just been exploding in
fact this says 102
000 in this old screenshot um if i can
actually find
what it's been pretty nuts her channels
go
fast and she is
growing because of posting
consistently and
here we go mary's nest if you don't know
mary you gotta subscribe
for that man when i took this screenshot
she was at a hundred 100
232 000 now mary's nest
traditional cooking for the modern
pioneer
mary is absolutely smashed haven't
started her youtube channel yet
and uh she has been again posting
consistently and also strategically but
it's been powerful i mean and we've seen
a lot of people now actually get their
silver play buttons
starting even from scratch or just
getting started on youtube
ranking their videos but here's number
two all right so you gotta post
consistently
that's just your frequency and that's
where most people
kind of stay stuck it's kind of quote
that says the definition of insanity is
doing the same thing over and over and
expecting different results
so you might be like sean i'm posting
like all the time dude i post super
consistently
well you might be doing the same thing
over and over but it's not working
that's because there's other dimensions
of consistency that you need number two
assistant message consistent
message so consistency is about
frequency
but it's also about your messaging okay
so that means you're saying the same
thing
kind of over and over like if you're
saying
a million different things then it's
going to be really confusing to follow
you
like what is the consistency of
your message you actually really want to
be predictably
unpredictable like you want people to
discover new things from you but
you mean we're doing all right here i
think marketing and think media and some
people are like
sean you say the same thing apparently
it's working
like we're on a mission to help 10 000
people create a full-time living doing
what they love with online video
like sean you keep talking about like
youtube you keep talking about like
clarity and consistency and stuff that's
because you gotta do the fundamentals
like but what is your message are saying
the same message consistently because if
you're going in a hundred different
directions how can anybody follow you
they don't know where you're going all
right so let me ask you
do you know what you stand for do you
know what you stand
what is your message what is the
consistent
message that people can rally around
when it comes
to your content and your channel
not just consistent content but
consistent messaging
you know i have a couple of examples of
people that i think are really good at
this
uh i think the successful content
creator of all time
is jesus christ you didn't see that one
think about i mean
besides from my belief the creator of
all content in the first place
at least the raw material for content
but when i think about
the most uh the largest religion in the
world is christianity the best-selling
book of all time is the bible
and authored and inspired from jesus
right that
work has spread around the world
influencing people very polarizing
and no matter what you believe there is
a consistent message
that went forth and it wasn't like
multiple different messages
it was this consistent message of the
gospel of hope and salvation
the gospel of the kingdom and there was
a consistent message jesus knew what he
stan
stood for what he stood against some
people are against him
some people are for him but i'm asking
you what's your
flag in the ground what's your
consistent message
wow on the way to a thousand subscribers
yeah you want to reach a thousand
subscribers don't just
post consistent videos
have a consistent message in
your content if you're getting value
smash the like button
and uh here's an example of my friend
nick grayscale gorilla
he's got a consistent message helping
people learn
cinema 4d helping people create
sometimes
advance in their career freelance in
their career more
you know your message doesn't have to be
super super crazy or anything it's just
consistent
this is uh tara she's a part of one of
our masterminds ready to crush your
goals and not your soul
i love that right join your get out of
my way challenge so she's helping people
with personal development get out of
your own head
but like it's a consistent message
4 000 subscribers she crossed that 1 000
subscriber mark if you're ready to grow
dial in your messaging but in my opinion
that's not enough number three
consistent value consistent value
all right so you don't just have
consistent content that's like frequency
you don't just have a consistent message
that's knowing what you stand for what
you stand against
and saying the same thing over and over
in new ways
being predictable or predictably
unpredictable being fresh
original but saying a lot of the same
things
if i go off on this slight tangent i
think about dave ramsey if you've ever
heard about him personal finance
will help you get out of debt dude has
built one of the biggest brands and
biggest empires
and if you listen to his content he
doesn't say a whole lot of new things
that's the power of it who would have
thought that the basic
fundamental truths that always work
will keep working again and again and
again
you're trying to look for some new stuff
all the time why don't you just do the
fundamentals you know michael jordan
come on the last dance he has a quote
master the fundamentals and everything
else you'll do will rise
why are you looking for like new
strategies and new youtube tips how
about you do the fundamentals that work
okay so not just consistent content
consistent messaging
but then consistent value what do i mean
by consistent
value well consistent value i think
about liv bay lash
mike and sauna shawna jones they uh
they help lash artists they don't just
do lash tutorials how to put on lashes
but they help lash artists um
make more money so like how to
uh lash ex you know like get
better tips how to get clients uh where
to buy your materials
so think about their target audience
like they not only have
uh an ecommerce store where they sell
glue and lashes
they don't not only have physical lash
places where they employ
and contract different lash artists but
then they've got a podcast and a youtube
channel that actually
helps eyelash professionals or
beauticians or something forgive me
whatever they're called like learn these
skills
and so they provide consistent value to
that target
i hope you get consistent value from
listening to the think marketing podcast
i hope you get consistent value
from going to think media and we're
we're wanting to deliver
consistent value to help you learn your
camera
to help you learn the strategies to grow
your influence with online video
to help you learn how to live stream to
help you stand out with your content
to help you learn the iceberg underneath
the youtube channel of email marketing
and how do you build a real business and
how do you stand out in the marketplace
and how do you master your personal
brand
it's a consistent value i'm not helping
you get the biceps i don't got a lot of
credibility there because i don't got
the biceps
i'm not going to help you you know
figure out your macros and figure out
how to get into ketosis because that's
not the value i'm providing
what value do you provide
and how are you can providing that value
consistently
furthermore though are you keeping it at
a standard of quality this is where we
go a little deeper let's get you to a
thousand subscribers buckle your
seatbelt if you're ready to hit a
thousand subscribers
here's the analogy my friends what's
your favorite restaurant drop that in
the comments for me what is your
favorite restaurant
if you think about going to your
favorite restaurant
last night my wife and i had ramen from
ramen kobo here in vegas
um one of my favorite restaurants fast
food wise i don't eat a ton of fast
foods in and out burger
so when i think about consistent value
when i go to in and out what do i expect
i expect some animal style fries come on
cook to perfection i want to have some
of that cheese on top some of that like
you know pink sauce with the kind of
pickles in it whatever that stuff's kind
of like a thousand island dressing in
there
i even want to get the little spicy
things diced up on their little peppers
i want to get a cheeseburger protein
style with the lettuce around it
and it's consistent i go there i know
what i'm going to get
if i want to have a consistently poor
cup of coffee i'm going to go to
starbucks
i at least know it's going to taste
consistently awful come on
anybody love starbucks so what's your
favorite
gaston says the cheesecake factory
somebody said the melting pot what is
one of your
what's your favorite restaurant here's
what would happen
if you go to your favorite restaurant
and all of a sudden you're like
dude these fries these are super stale
and cold
this burger is like a hockey puck it's
like cardboard
and this coffee is cold it's supposed to
be hot this isn't an iced coffee
it's not that the coffee was just good
once or that the animal style fries from
in and out was just good once
they need to be good consistently am i
saying this is easy no
am i saying that this is the key to
break a thousand subscribers yes
don't just post videos on a consistent
basis
don't just know your messaging
and weave that into your videos and know
what your brand is and your positioning
is
consistently but you got to keep the
value high consistently
like i'm not entitled to you being here
and watching this video
i would think that if you started being
like dude dude fell off man
that this stuff sucks it's not
valuable any longer you're not going to
stay around very long
i'm not going to keep going to in-n-out
burger if the food is cold
i know that's hard but how do you keep
the value high
the value consistent you want people to
come back to your youtube channel for a
consistent experience
wow it wasn't just a good video and
educational or entertaining
but on a frequent basis one other
analogy you ever watched like a a
netflix show what's one of your favorite
netflix show
or hulu or disney plus or amazon prime
or hbo go come on what is what's one of
your favorite shows you gave it a shot
man first episode was good by the way
it's a consistent
you can binge watch the whole season so
it's all out but you have a consistent
episodes
the consistent message because the show
has a consistent theme and things going
through it
like episode one value is good episode
two that's kind of i don't know if i'm
gonna stick with this episode three
ah it's not it's not that strong episode
four
this thing's pretty terrible these shows
these episodes are boring
story's falling apart man i don't know
what happened that production value
like it sure started strong i can't even
hear the actors anymore i mean that's
probably not going to happen but you get
what i'm saying
you got to keep the value high that's
keeping the quality high it's having
quality standards
this is what it's about my friends let's
get you to a thousand subscribers
consistent videos consistent content
consistent
messaging consistent value okay i got
another uh tip number four coming up
and i got a bonus tip for you too uh but
uh that's one of the things live bae
lash is doing
i love uh lucia from plants and lucia
when she actually joined our community
um
she was at like zero i mean i remember i
got a screenshot she had like 100
subscribers she's at 12 000 subscribers
now
but she's not only posting consistently
she's got a consistent message
plants gardening you know how to make a
moss pole
you know your plant summer tour it's
consistently valuable people love it
because
she's also listen look at her joy on her
face she's showing up consistently
man i know what to expect lucia i'm
getting she's going to welcome me
i'm going to learn about some plants man
i like her energy
it's consistent i know what i'm going to
get and i bet even if you're just
meeting lucia right now
you know what you're going to get when
you watch
the plants and lucia channel so we're
going to get to the next one in a second
but if you want to go deep
deeper on this today's episode of coffee
with candles brought to you by
the think master class if you want to
learn
some tactics of how to break out how to
rank videos in search get your videos to
show up in suggested videos trigger the
youtube algorithm
and you haven't seen my free one hour
master class i'll break down help you
with titles thumbnails a lot of other
things like that link in the description
below
think masterclass.com if you want to
watch that
and uh you'll love it if you haven't
seen it and we will get to some q a in
just a bit
but um check that out number four before
our bonus tip
consistent branding so you got the
consistent content the consistent
message
the consistent value do you have the
consistent branding
you know a brand is i believe what
people think about when they think about
you
what do you think about when you think
about walmart what do you think about
when you think about nordstrom or neiman
marcus
what do you think about when you think
about gucci
what do you think about when you think
about champion
you know what do you think about when
you think about ferrari
or kia consistent branding
what people think about when they think
about you now this might be kind of your
colors your website your music
again it's consistent if you want to
stand out my friend and we're on our way
to a thousand subscribers if you want to
stand out
there's something about people you
resonating in the marketplace what makes
you different what makes you
unique and staying consistent with that
branding now i think about this coffee
with candle show we don't got any music
i don't know how to how do i do that in
stream yard like what would i do i don't
know
i wouldn't have got any logos but we
just have a consistent show
where i show up i teach for 10 to 15
minutes bring
guests on the show and i just keep
saying the same thing i'm going to help
you build your influence income and
impact
right we're on a mission to help 10 000
people create a full-time living with
online video that's our company mission
you know we're here we're after we're
helping purpose-driven entrepreneurs
help you achieve success without losing
your soul let's talk about youtube let's
get your grind right your mind right
your hustle on your hustle fixed
what are you drinking let me know in the
comments so your branding
again is just that consistency
on the mildly caffeinated somewhat
eccentric
small town kid college dropout that
started making videos in my bedroom and
built a little empire like
i don't know i don't know what are my
colors trying to figure it out
you know but what's your consistent
brand and
and and i think your consistent branding
is how people can help
you grow to 1000 subscribers this is uh
christina again these are all video
ranking academy
members um that we've been talking about
so she has
beloved women which is like a bible
study channel
but if you look at her thumbnails right
you got that consistent smile that
consistent pink
kind of that consistent look she's doing
some awesome stuff with like merch and
journals
and some different things that she's
doing and it's just a really powerful
channel
i think again it's not just the colors
it's not just those things but it's also
just the kind of messaging how to get
started as a christian writer how to
become a better christian writer how to
become a confident christian speaker
and different things trusting god during
the pandemic consistent branding
cowboy kent rowlands he crossed a
thousand a little while ago
1.2 million and uh he was a part of our
mastermind recently
but but when i think about the branding
not just the thumbnails
not just the look but i mean the cowboy
hat
come on that amazing mustache if you
don't got the handlebar mustache you
aren't living yet
right so he's cowboy cooking what a
brand
you see what i'm saying what and and and
i know you might be like sean well i'm
not sure what my brand is
you know i'm not really sure you know
even what my message is yet hey that's
okay
that's why you're watching this if you
work on these things let me encourage
you
i'm not trying to i just wanted to show
you some examples for inspiration
i'm not trying to say you got to get
these things right you probably weren't
even thinking about these things
like a lot of the people teaching
youtube out there are just being like yo
post videos consistently they even tell
you the rest of the tips
like dial in your message
dial in your brand raise the value of
your content
and then show up over and over and my
friend you're gonna get
to a thousand subscribers remember
success is not magical nor mysterious
right it's the natural consequence
of consistently applying
the basic fundamentals all right i got a
tip for you
a bonus tip and then i've got uh we're
going to bring some guests on
the show for coffee with ken back in las
vegas
excited to be here excited to be with
you i broke my slides what's going on
here
today's episode is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
if you're ready to grow your youtube
channel faster and you want to not just
apply these four strategies but dive
down
into the tactics working right now to
really get views and subscribers and you
have not seen
think master class go to
thinkmasterclass.com you can just enter
your name and email there and then it
gives you
access to a one hour free training
that's a part of our video ranking
academy at the end of it you'll hear
about our full-on academy
and whether that's right for you or not
no pressure no worries it's all good
but you definitely should check out this
free master class because i break down a
lot of tactics and strategies that you
can apply right now
to get massive results if you've been
getting value hit the like button
i want to remind you that commitment is
the foundation of great
accomplishments so you want to hit a
thousand subscribers stay committed you
want to hit a thousand subscribers keep
posting
you want to hit a thousand subscribers
stay focused you want to hit a thousand
subscribers
apply these four principles and the
fifth bonus tip i have for you
is consistent motivation
i think one of the hardest parts about
making it on youtube
is a lot of people give up too soon they
give up before the breakthrough
they didn't realize you probably
realized but they didn't realize
the mental battle the emotional battle
the energy battle that it takes
to post consistent content to come up
with creative ideas
to show up powerfully to hit the record
button
to punch fear in the face and we're not
going to go into it today but if you
want that fifth edge
on how to get to a thousand you got to
stay consistently motivated
so my question is just asking yourself
man how can i keep my motivation at a
ten
what do i do to get out of a rut and to
get my mind right when my mind starts
going wrong
how do i punch anxiety in the face and
discouragement in the face
and get focused so that i can put out
the best content possible for me
i think that one of the keys to getting
to a thousand subscribers
is actually overcoming discouragement
and resistance that keeps us
procrastinating and not posting
that keeps us obsessed with
perfectionism instead of
posting our next imperfect video because
done is better than perfect
so i just want to encourage you stay
focused get locked in
apply these four tips and if you want
some more strategies
check out thinkmasterclass.com
hit the like button if you're getting
value i appreciate you so much i'm
excited for our uh coffee with kennel
it's been a minute i'm in vegas here
let me know what you're drinking we're
going to bring annie on the show here
annie how are we going
where are you watching from uh what's
going on
in your life in business hi good evening
everyone i'm a part of the world it's
night time i'm watching from malaysia
and thank you so much for putting me in
live
yeah actually that you're here what is
your youtube channel
um it's andy lawrence a nie
okay awesome and um what's uh what's
been happening kind of in your
uh what's your question today okay i
just want to
get some advice because actually when i
started on this channel
it's just about um posting um how-tos
from for our teachers actually i'm a
teacher in
school um here in malaysia and then
i did post some how-to videos for my
teachers but then i ended up why don't i
just
put it up for a bigger reach so that's
how i started last june
so this channel was just i started out
of that
and then um when i started i came up i
saw your videos and that's how
i started it just how i put it up just
like that
with thumbnails and tags and all that
just by following a video so
it's been like a month uh two months now
so that's how i started well first of
all i mean
you're already doing amazing i love the
consistency because with the four
uploads that's
averaging one a week 43 new subscribers
in the last month 7 000 views you've
already got crazy momentum in my opinion
for the fact that you're really only
about 13 videos in
so i just want to say good job right off
the bat
uh but is there a specific question that
you feel like you're getting stuck with
or
i think what i would want is like an
advice most especially um like what can
i do better
um and how can i even um like um
let's say build more on this channel
because my niche was supposed to be on
online teaching
um so i like put it up there but um any
any pointers that i could just
put in i've been watching your video and
i got really
very great tips from there but um
specifically for this channel thank you
great great great so um a couple things
um
you know my first and most basic advice
is just kind of echoing what i just said
keep going like keep doing what you're
doing because you're getting i mean i
know a lot of people watching would
be just inspired and would love to have
a breakout video with the 5 000
views here or even get a couple hundred
views per video um my second tip though
is i would like to see less words in
your thumbnails
you don't need to um
like echo the title in your thumbnails
this is something that a lot of people
do
by you know your title here how to
increase zoom meeting time for free
really great title um and then you know
you might just have you theoretically
could just have the zoom logo
and say like three because people are
going to
look at the thumbnail and then they're
going to read the title and so what
we've been trying to do over on think
media
is doing a lot of this came out today on
think media get noticed just two words
and the social media
logos so if any words do less words
budget youtube studio
simple youtube studio setup for
beginners works with any camera
you kind of want to hook the attention
with the thumbnail first
and then have people read the title and
then in some
cases videos are doing great that have
no words at all
because you go oh wow what's what's that
cool lighting road microphone and then
budget microphone youtube setup
so i think that's one thing you could do
immediately is don't think that you need
to
echo all the words that are in the title
in your thumbnail think about
and you don't even need to repeat them
sometimes you can
say something in the thumbnail that is
not in the title at
all if it kind of grabs attention
like free boom you know just like that
you know that would kind of be what
people want like i want zoom for free or
different things like that so that would
be a tip does that make sense
okay great thank you so much thank you
thanks a lot
absolutely and i'll i'll give you one
more i think uh the next thing is
like double down on what's working and i
want everybody to hear that
um like i think it's
definitely zoom is so massive right now
and you're doing a lot on that so like
keep going on those specific
questions that's what we like to
encourage people to do asq
answer specific questions and so
here would be like a little way to
research and i talked more about this on
the think master class
but if you were to type in like zoom um
you could go
underscore before zoom and it'll tell us
like
how to use the zoom app so that's a
video you can make how to use zoom
meeting
how to download the zoom app on a laptop
now that's kind of a good example
because you may have not have thought to
make a video like that it's very basic
but this is what we talk about like
answer specific questions
answer just like specific ques i mean
how to join a zoom meeting these are the
types of things
how to download zoom in a laptop and so
if you're looking for video ideas
these really practical we call it the 4s
strategy
stupid starter specific um
simple questions simple stupid specific
starter questions that's the 4s
strategy because again you might go
well it's easy to download zoom app on a
laptop
but but a lot of people don't know how
to do that and so
that's stupid like like the book
facebook for dummies cooking for dummies
are like okay i don't know how to use
zoom like hold my hand teach me
a specific thing one video one question
right
and then it's like um you know simple
these are very simple things too if it
was like how to make
a mult you know to do a virtual
conference with 50 speakers
with like no one's doing that like
what's like where get really empathetic
for the type of people you're helping
the teachers that you're helping
and when you use the 4s strategy um
with asq answer specific questions it'll
be very powerful
level with thumbnails um and then just
keep doing what you're doing because you
already are doing really you have got
great momentum
like i want you to be inspired because
it does take time it takes about 30 to
50 videos to kind of trigger the youtube
algorithm
you're already triggering it and so um
alice and annie sorry annie
uh i appreciate you and i'm grateful um
that you were part of coffee with kennel
today
yeah am i still here i think she froze
but uh grateful for annie smash the like
button if you got value
what's a specific question you could
answer
in your niche uh let me know
uh give me a question drop it down
below and um let me know if i'm actually
still
on the internet maybe it was just annie
that froze
uh chris what up uh where are you
watching from am i still streaming live
uh what's your job yeah you're here i
can see you sean loud and clear all good
all right cool yeah i'm in new york
um i got my coffee um it's grady's
i don't know the brand too well but it's
really good concentrated iced coffee
um but yeah so i'm a vra member
just started a couple weeks ago getting
a lot of value out of the facebook page
and the um community it's really been
helpful
um i started my page or my channel
called drone careers
um my intention is to start a recruiting
website
uh with job job postings and job
listings in the drone industry
um i haven't um i haven't launched a
website
um the platforms i'm focused on are now
instagram and youtube
um i built up about 4 000 followers on
facebook
and i decided to shift gears to
instagram and youtube
um just a quick side note i used to work
for youtube um i've been doing
video on youtube for almost 15 years um
i'm not a creator i work on the branded
partnership side
so i've been doing i've been
providing creators with revenue for
years massive creators like unbox
therapy and
you know lots of different ones but um
i've seen so many people do it
and now i'm like quarantine's given me
the time
to basically start my channel and start
my business so
pretty excited about it i love it chris
and so has the channel already started
yeah so um i started about two weeks ago
um i've got i think six or seven videos
um my videos are really focused on
answering questions that i've gotten
from search queries
either in google or youtube um i haven't
really gotten that down to a science yet
i'm trying to figure out like what's the
best way to do keyword research
um around search queries my query
uh so my my keyword research is really
um it's focused around
um questions people have around
different industries or different uses
for commercial drones
so um drones is first responders drones
in agriculture
um private sector versus public sector
jobs
um so my content
so i've had a couple big questions
lately and i put these on the um
on the message board for the community
but
um first of all it's like either so we
could cover this question which is
probably good
um 16 9 versus one by one video
um my my issue is that
um it's time when i create a video it
can range anywhere between three to five
hours
um if i do a one by one video i can put
that on every platform and it'll look
really good
um it's just that youtube is still kind
of stuck between the 169 to the one by
one
and i don't know if i'm if i'm one by
one on youtube
is that potentially holding me back from
getting distribution
um so i'd love to hear your thoughts on
that directly i think that would be a
good question to cover
it's a great question um you know on the
one hand
i think the forward momentum the fact
you're posting
the fact you're getting content up is
like in a way better than nothing i
think can be valuable
and uh is valuable even as you're just
getting started you know some of these
how to get started in real estate drone
photography he's got 42 views
answering a specific question so it's
kind of a good example
you know two likes you're right at the
beginning
right now but it is working so i mean on
on one level
yes it's working uh two i think that
technically youtube's not going to
penalize you there's plenty of
vertical videos and and youtube will
also go native on mobile like youtube
app will know to go
native and make vertical videos or make
square so
um youtube is going to reward you
on the peer merit of the video that we
all get judged on
average view duration click through rate
you know consumption and
those are the big ones watch time and
click-through rate but
of course consumption engagement and
even viewer satisfaction
so really could you succeed with
one one by one i think absolutely
there's no reason not to
but the third or there's no reason why
you wouldn't really be able to but my
third thought
is it is always best to optimize for
the platform that you're on and i would
even go more strategic and say
i think it's best for you to reverse
engineer
what it is that you want to happen and i
want to talk about a marketing concept
called
um the chocolate-covered carrot and
a big thing that we can fall into is we
answer questions people are not asking
when we should be answering the
questions they are asking so we get a
chance
to add answer the questions they don't
know to ask the reason it's called the
chocolate covered carrot
is sometimes a lot of people they don't
want the nutritious carrot like trying
to feed a kid some vegetables
they want the chocolate so my thought is
you potentially could attract
thousands of aspiring people here's a
couple thoughts
they may like what level are they at
do they know they just want to do
something fun and do a new career
like that could be the level of
understanding they're at do they know
they're into drones but didn't even know
they could make money from that
are they just kind of into drones as a
hobby and you could entertain them
or you know bring them in by creating a
certain type of content and then say hey
by the way
if you actually would want to know how
to make drones like
a career then you know you can even
watch my free master class or something
or watch this free playlist on youtube
and you can start helping educating and
bringing them into your world
so that's what i also think is of course
the format but if we go a little bit
bigger
in terms of these are great videos but
they're
they're super niche and that's good so
like it's great that
you know drone healthcare tribute in
spain or you know some of these other
things
but i actually i just want to especially
thanks for being a part of
video ranking academy um encourage you
to
potentially think a little bigger dream
a little bigger
and and then think about how ethically
we want to put out chocolate covered
carrots it's the question and the desire
people
actually want it's the chocolate but
then it's the nutrition
and the carrot they actually need that's
the you know the carrot
and so my thought is even if there's you
know drone kind of con like drone
montages
4k drone footage so that's just kind of
a thought too and that sort of stuff is
going to perform best
in crispy 16 9 4k so i sort of took your
question a little bit further there
um but in the meantime you're saying it
takes about five hours to produce a
video i get that
i wouldn't maybe also think so myopic
in just this one content format i think
another strategy
when i think content formats is these
follow a particular pattern great you
could try other things though like why
can't it be you talking head
why can't it just be a montage of drone
footage you've shot
why can't there be other and you know
again i'm talking about like the next
years of building this out but i think
that um
summarizing it back to one by one better
than nothing in my opinion
absolutely could perform well you could
have a breakout video
but 16x9 content
that would perform well on youtube
the chocolate if you will content that
will attract viewers bring awareness
and then once you have awareness you
have the chance
to people go what i don't even know you
could have job listings and news and
they discover
you because and and the most chocolatey
content that we could possibly post on
youtube
is going to be 16x9 widescreen is my
point
is that helpful does that make sense
yeah it's great it's uh
it's great uh feedback i you know i
really want to
um you know i i followed a lot in the
course gary academy about
um you know choosing what i want to be
whether i'm a creator or a publisher or
a media company
i'm really um you know i'm really a
business slash
uh media company but i wanna i wanna
take what creators do really well and
apply it to my business because i've
seen it work so well
um so i think that's 169 or creating
that chocolatey video i think would be a
great approach
um and that's ultimately what i want to
do is like cast a wide net get people
really interested in my channel
and then ultimately build um a business
using youtube but not necessarily making
my entire business on youtube so i'm
creating
um influence creating equity around my
brand
using youtube but i think yeah that's a
great uh that's a great approach i mean
one thing i could do is basically take
all the one by one and put it into its
own playlist
and i'm trying to make these videos as
like
search query questions or search query
answers to like
you know questions around like what how
are drones used in agriculture how are
drones used by fire departments or
police agencies so
um this is really helpful really
appreciate it i'll let somebody else get
on but i can talk to you for
a long time sean but i really appreciate
it i'm i'm really deep in the content
right now
awesome chris well i appreciate you
great for your part of vra and of course
of course tony areola is in there and
whatnot
quick tip of the week and vra show so i
look forward to uh connecting with you
more inside of the
private facebook group as well awesome
thanks again
take care chris all right hey
uh coffee with kennel if you're just
joining this is the bi-weekly
q a show where uh we bring you on the
show
if you're looking for the 1000
subscriber tips those are at the
beginning of the stream of course the
replay will be left up so you can always
watch that
make sure you're subscribed or you like
the page wherever you're watching this
and our schedule now is every other week
we're doing with coffee with kannel and
then we have the think marketing q a
show
with heather taurus and melissa caputo
and other members
from the think media team um if you're
grateful
to be alive even in the midst of crazy
times
smash the like button or gently touch
the like button
on whatever platform you're on um we
have nancy michelle here
today nancy where are you watching from
what's your business
what's your youtube channel how can i
help on
i've spoken to you before i don't know
if you remember me but
i did everything well in my opinion
i did everything you told me to do and
i'm hoping
you like what i did and i just want to
get your input on
what you think i'm a little bit uh
a little bit more subscribers than um
i'm not gonna say that that's mean i'm
just gonna say
i have a little more subscribers i know
you guys usually talk about getting the
first
1000 subscribers um but
i am i think at 400
something like that so what's the
channel
uh mommy shark oh yeah yeah yeah hey
mommy shark
yeah yeah yeah all i needed i'm now
sharing my name so i'm like yeah
i'll just share my name but yeah um
so i'm getting 900 around 900
subs a month amazing but
i want to get more i'm greedy
i'm just kidding i just want more
so um so yeah i just wanted to get your
thoughts
because i completely changed the banner
i completely
i started giving away stuff
too and um and then
i change my thumbnails and
i know things are looking good about a
video a week about
a thousand subscribers a month 50 000
views yeah
yeah loving it are probably not as
aggressive because if you remember you
told me like they're very
red and blue they were too aggressive
and
so i changed those um some are better
than others
like those some of them i left and i was
like this is too much to go back and
change
but yeah yeah yeah yeah but i i like
them i think they they look
crispy they look like they're doing well
and a couple
definitely the uh these pumping best
bras with the willow and lv
pump that's doing good like you're
talking about the pumps too much
so ever since then i tried to expand a
little bit more
even though those videos don't do well
for me that well for
me sure and i think that's a you know
that kind of brings us into like
depth verse width you know eventually in
our brands
or or what we discover is that there's a
lot of stuff for with
in terms of uh you know i think media we
know that it's like it's like knowing
what will lead to what could be vanity
metrics like sure it's impact but it's
just kind of like
you know think about people you follow
like there's some people i follow like
i'm not trying to like
follow them all the time follow them on
all the social media platforms like go
super deep with them
i'm like that's just like my dude that's
my girl for this
one kind of piece of information and
every and even algorithmically
if i've consumed a video from them maybe
about a breast pump
then it's going to hit the home page for
me in the future but it's a very
shallow view nothing wrong with that
because you want to reach really
wide when it comes to youtube the power
of i think some of these
other topics and as you're talking about
grieving
or talking about other things that are
less popular you never want to downplay
that
because that's depth i mean i think
about coffee with cannell like what
we're doing right now this is probably
the deepest level of depth you're
literally
on the show and we're like at creating
content here together
one to one and um this particular video
it's not gonna go viral it's not gonna
be we're just reviewing our content for
the last year you know we have a couple
videos at two million views four million
views this will not be a with video
but it's a depth video and i hope that
this kind of show builds more community
so that is something to think about too
in terms of your channel i would
definitely be doing both
be thinking about putting out videos
that reach new viewers
reach new subscribers you almost know
they'll be popular
you're almost placating two vanity
metrics
with the hope and the invitation that
you also would create like my friend
super
uh pat flynn says super fans kind of
you're a thousand true fans
unto whatever your sort of business
and community goals are right so
anything screaming at you from looking
at my page
anything like oh my gosh no this is
horrible this needs to change
i i like i like the new branding i like
your positioning back to the four tips
at the beginning
you know problem solver truth seller uh
teller
you know uncensored you know you kind of
have that raw and i would say that i
love that you know
so i think that's strong um i i do like
the thumbnails
now um and i guess it goes back to
the main thing would just be success
leaves clues that we talked about this
last time
and i'd be looking for you know uh
four months ago the newest videos that
are performing the best of course you've
got your
old hits but um versus video that's a
good point we've been telling
for everybody watching this either even
on the replay the versa strategy
there's there's something so powerful
it's literally in your top four of it no
it's
it's in your top three three out of your
top four videos
are the verses strategy yes so
do you have any more versus videos
coming up no
because these are i mean i can
these are very uh
awesome products that nobody else is
competing with right now on the market
see it's
these is there other mommy
products you could do versus of that
are spin-off a little bit from breast
pumps
that's a good question i would have to
do a research i mean that's
good that no noted there you go
and there's a lot of verses and for
everybody watching write that strategy
down the versus strategy
um heather just uh we posted a video on
think media
about that to go a little bit deeper but
it's a lot of people they don't know
you but they know like well i'm
wondering do i get the willow
gen 3 or the lv pump you know which one
do i get and then
this video shows up so i think you know
thinking about success leaves clues
let me ask you another question where do
you want this to lead
like are you trying to hit a certain you
know not just impact but a financial
target
are you trying to start channel
memberships make it just with youtube
ads trying to get brand deals like what
do you want to happen
i want to be able to do it full time to
be honest with you
um i'm still like
cranking out a video a week but i still
can't
support myself right now just doing that
so
and i actually tried i tried to release
a course
and i want i pre-sold to see if anybody
would care
and i have so many people that signed up
but nobody wants to pay for it so i'm
still not there i'm still not there
and i don't have credibility like i'm i
don't have i'm not a lactation
consultant i'm not a doctor
i'm not a nurse so i noticed that when
you don't have that that makes the
huge difference but i'm not even trying
to sell medical information if that
makes sense like i don't
anyway yeah so that's what i'm trying to
do right now
and yeah but i bought a ticket to your
conference very excited about that and
yeah
but yeah good good to know i just
to be honest with you i just want to go
viral like everybody else
yep yep well here's here's the um
the thing i would say you know i i think
the next
since your goal is to take with the
subscribers that you have
with the 10 000 that you're going to hit
in the next three months
um i am absolutely confident that you're
going to be able to get to full time
i'll give you the four pillars that
you're going to be learning at growth
video live and so thank you for getting
a ticket
um here they are if if everybody
watching this is worth writing down
we're going to be really because you
want to think about these for your brand
personally whether you come to the
conference or not
but purpose purpose driven we want to be
purpose-driven entrepreneurs but we want
to start with the end in mind everything
we do is intentional
purpose like where is it you want to end
up
you know you don't want to climb the
wrong mountain only to realize
you reached the top and you climbed the
wrong mountain um
and what is it when you work backwards
not that you need to become a lactation
consultant or certified or whatever but
maybe you do because
if if there is some kind of target you
then reverse engineer back from it and
say
well what would need to happen for this
thing to work
and let me then do that thing so that
thing works so that's just purpose we're
then going to be talking about
uh promotion or positioning is next
positioning is the second p and your
positioning
is thinking about who are you in the
market what i do like again
and censored truth s teller researcher
how are you different
and so under positioning i was just on a
zoom call with chris ducker who wrote
the book youpreneur
um you know also who does virtual
staffing stuff one of our speakers
so like he's one of the foremost experts
in helping people really clarify and
refine their personal brand
and so we'll be helping you uh with
positioning
but that's a great thing to dial down in
what is it about
what what gap do i fill in the in the
world what
what is my piece of of the market you
know what's my uniqueness and you're
already refining that but we want that
to constantly get stronger we just went
through a two-day staff retreat
on virtual so it's really a retreat uh
home office retreat
uh but we you know we're working not in
our business but on our business here at
think media and think marketing
and we're always thinking about our
positioning different is better than
better what makes us different and so
that's number two the third one is then
promotion and you're gonna love that so
these are the three days at our event
um what are the best promotion
strategies right now for getting more
views getting more subscribers you know
we got katherine from contentbug and
vanessa lau
and uh silicon valley girl and roberto
blake we got a lot of people
so people are gonna be sharing about
youtube as well as other platforms and i
think
leaving the conference you'll be
thinking about where maybe else should i
be
um but then of course the fourth p is
profit
and what are the best ways to monetize
and
for you i think that leaving the
conference it'll be about
clarity by thinking because yes
it could be the course it could be doing
the course the right way it could be
channel memberships it could be
something like that
but it also could be something else and
it may not be easy but it'll be worth it
because your income is directly
correlated to the amount of buy buttons
you have on your website and
if that's creating something to sell
it's creating a product maybe that is
a subscription or a membership maybe
that is
partnering with a company one of our um
like members of
that's been with us for a while nicole
is working on like a kind of a brand
partnership and sort of becoming
a brand ambassador at a deep level like
not doing tons of brand deals
like what if you just did one brand deal
for two years because you've got a brand
you've got a personality you know how to
create content
and you potentially could earn multiple
six figures or like over six figures a
year
because of the skill set and the brand
that you've built
when you've done your positioning right
so that
you attract and synergize with the right
brand
we have people walking in that and we're
going to be talking about she's actually
speaking at her conference too nicole
eaton so
um anyways those are the four p's just
to kind of get you pumped
and for time's sake of course we got to
keep going but you're gonna love
grow with video live you know getting
clear on our purpose starting with the
end in mind
mastering our positioning uh learning
the best
and latest promotional tactics across
all online video and social media
platforms
and then how do we profit how do we
monetize and
um you know find the best monetization
strategies
increase our current revenue streams and
things like that yeah i'm excited
and i did want to say one thing one of
those companies did reach out to me
and they want me to be in their ad so
that that's cool
there you go that's awesome and that's
and that's that's just getting started
mommy shark yeah mommy
yeah oh one last question sean one last
question if i wanted to rebrand
to my name is that a big no-no at this
point
because everybody it was define me
through mommy shark
or should i do what you do you're like
sean kennel at
think media i could be nancy at
exactly i i you could combine it and it
it still could say
mommy shark uh nancy the mommy shark
or mommy shark with nancy michelle
like or or i could just say mommy shark
and you could start introducing yourself
more
and you could be on the cover where uh
where it says
like nancy michelle potentially on it so
i think i think they can almost become
interchangeable hey what's up everybody
welcome back to mommy shark i'm nancy
and i'm so excited
you know like you could sort of you know
hey what's up everybody welcome to think
marketing think media my name's sean
cannell and
um yeah i would say don't overthink that
too much you do want to think it through
but but don't feel stuck at all
especially you're still relatively early
in the journey but even still
um if that's a pivot you want to make i
would actually make it sooner than later
kind of think through what that brand
will be and then just go for it right
well thank you sean i really appreciate
it nancy i appreciate you so much
pumped you're gonna be a part of growth
video live and uh we'll see you there
thanks have a good one take care
hey uh that was fun my friends um i'm
gonna take a sip of water and we're
gonna do
i think a couple more uh probably two
more uh guests
here um but if you haven't heard about
growth video live yet
are you coming did you get your tickets
growethvideolive.com
um check out this really short promo
and uh we'll be back for some more
questions 65 percent of people use
youtube to help
them solve a problem but when i think
about this here's the question
all of us need to answer what problem
do you solve you got to know that and
when you know that people are going to
the internet they go to google they go
to youtube to help solve a problem
you need to be showing up with those
[Music]
answers
grow with video live the virtual
experience is happening september
8th through the 10th 2020
online in your living room on your
smartphone
in the break room at work in your air
pods on the walk with your dog
it's gonna be amazing and a lot of guest
speakers a lot of powerful content
planned this is not some uh
you know thrown together duct tape
virtual experience
this is a massive virtual experience
that's stressing us out to be quite
honest but we got plenty of time to
figure it out
dynamic we will be at a venue here in
vegas
we will be able to bring guests on kind
of like coffee with cannel
there's going to be a whole networking
experience going through an app called
socio
and it's three days it's absolutely
massive and it's only 97
is the lowest lowest ticket price to be
a part of the whole thing and there's a
few other different um
packages you can see go to
growthvideolive.com
you're not going to want to miss it
again we're going to help you get clear
on your purpose
figure out your positioning what's your
niche you know how are you
different is better than better where
you position in the market
um mastering the latest promotion
strategies how do you get views
how do you get subscribers what other
social media platforms should you be
focusing on
how do you balance and how do you pick
the right platform for you
with experts like michaela alexis
talking about linkedin video stephanie
liu talking about facebook live rachel
miller talking about
facebook organic people think facebook's
dead this week's
think marketing podcast you can hear
rachel miller
talking about all the organic reach
she's getting on facebook when people
don't think that's possible
we are bringing together the best of the
best and then of course profit
um how do you profit how do you pivot
your plan right now
and what are the best ways to generate
revenue and build your
income with video growwithvideolive.com
is the website marcus welcome to coffee
with kannel where are you watching from
what's your youtube channel and how can
i help today absolutely i'm joining you
from basel in switzerland here in
western europe
um my channel is marcus sipper i like my
little name card there
and marcus with the k and cephala
s-e-p-p-a-l-a
and i am a stand-up comedian and speaker
and on my channel i try to help people
engage better with the audience whether
that's in the comedy club or in a
professional presentation so it's all
about like
communication advice some of it is on
stage
somebody's also now with with virtual i
have like a lot of good
success with a couple of zoom related
videos so that's kind of the the niche
that i'm going for
and i got a lot of value out of the
whole think family so far
but uh but here's my question that's
been been on my mind
i understand that one of the most
profitable niches
is personal finance and
i and specifically there's one topic
that i'm passionate about that is
financial independence
so i've been considering starting a
second challenge
channel about financial independence uh
i understand this very profitable i also
kind of researched the competition a
little bit
there isn't like the competition is not
that high quality
so my question kind of is how should i
think about
you know what process should i go
through to figure out if it's a good
idea to start that
second channel or not and i'm only three
months into this journey so it may be
too early but i'm
unsure how to make that decision yeah i
love the question
and i love how you're thinking because
you've hit a point right now where you
thought
you're thinking about some important
business terms like tam
the total addressable market maybe how
many people are interested in it
you're also thinking about we have that
kind of matrix of the intersection of
yes something you're passionate about
something you're proficient at which it
sounds like you would know about
personal finance
and then something that's also
profitable and to your point
the brand deals the affiliate programs
the people
using your robinhood link and all that
kind of stuff it's
outrageous actually how profitable
personal finance can be
so you go okay well that's a smart move
if i potentially
want to create a highly profitable and
impactful youtube channel
so the work you've already done i wanted
i broke that down so i think everybody
else would hear that
that that sometimes you may come to a
place in your youtube journey and you're
not even super far in terms of this
channel
where it's almost like you become aware
of well if i really want this to be
sustainable like for me
i i did daily vlogging for about 45 days
with my wife
and i mean we could have kept grinding
it out but i even just reverse
engineered like
i don't want to have the pressure to
vlog daily like i don't even know
i just you know it's like i don't want
to even do that and if somebody falls in
love with that it's what if it's what
they want to do but again it's alignment
of passion
lifestyle sustainability so
i guess my next thought is if you have
the clarity and confidence to rush into
that niche
i don't recommend you do two channels i
actually recommend you potentially
pause this channel or pivot
this channel because you're not that far
and it wouldn't hurt you to use the
momentum you've already had
but this is essentially what my sean
cannell channel is so
first and last name just like you i
don't even come up for my own channel i
mean think media so sean
sean cannell is right here and over the
years i've kind of like thrown stuff
there and it's definitely grown
kind of from the residual of my brand
and i've done a lot of like
smart kind of health products or ranked
videos um that have
also generated money along the way and
whatnot but here's my point
this is a mainly for the time being kind
of an
orphaned channel it's the last videos
three months ago you know i announced of
course we have a podcast here
but i just don't do much with it so i
guess it's if you start a second channel
i would almost want you to kind of shut
out of your mind
and really go all in with this new thing
because here's why
if you try and chase two rabbits you'll
end up catching neither
that's right it's the power of focus
it's the book essentialism
and it's the fact that even if you try
to fight the battle on two fronts
you're you're exhausting your resources
and your energy on each battle what
would happen if you took all of those
resources and energy and put them
towards one thing
and so i think the idea is sound i think
that
if you're feeling it and you've got that
clarity i think that's what i would want
you to consider next
it's a huge mistake i've also made my
friends in coffee with kennel overall
is i'm probably just like a lot of us as
entrepreneurs and creators we have tons
of different ideas there's so many
different things we want to do
and so you know at times
i'm trying to build video influence with
with benji i'm trying to stay consistent
on my personal channel i'm trying to
post tech reviews over on think media
i'm trying to write a book i'm trying to
keep a blog updated i'm trying to be
active on other social media
and then someone comes to me with a
business opportunity and is like hey do
you want to also sell like beachbody on
demand and i'm like that sounds great i
i love working out and that would be
cool too and and all of a sudden
you're you're involved in a hundred
different things somebody else is like
hey do you want to
like it and actually this can look like
a lot of our lives tell me in the
comments if you can relate to be
being fighting the battle on like seven
fronts
and if i look back over the last decade
especially what i've learned creating
content building an online brand
is i think man the power of focus and
it's trying to get
if you dabble in a few things to try and
discover clarity that's great
but man when you know what the one thing
is i think the smartest thing i've done
over the last couple years
was continuing to do less and less and
less
and figure out that for us it's just
think media
video influencers i do with benji but
i've kind of put it into a thing where
i'm like this is 10 of my time that's it
and i'll do some things to automate it
and when i'm up in seattle and whatnot
but i'm like
i know that that sits in that bucket and
then when we launched the think
marketing channel
we really launched it when a whole
another human existed
called heather taurus who who owns that
channel in the sense of
um you know runs it thinks about it tony
ariolis
so i took the one thing got it to such
scale
that by the way when i go back to sean
cannell and start talking about high
performance leadership
biohacking and maybe things like that
that i'd want to talk about on that
channel
this is what i'm getting at marcus i
want to do that now i just went on like
a little vacation i was like dude i'm so
pumped about getting back into my sean
kennel channel
and i hope the wisdom in me was like
that's probably not this year
it's probably not next year might not be
for three more years
because i need to stay focused on
one thing and really grow that thing and
keep growing that thing and then re
applying my blinders and my focus to
that one thing
i actually think that's one of the
hardest things in entrepreneurship even
some of my peers who are
at levels of success they find it
difficult
to stay focused and stick with something
for two years six years 12 years
15 years but my friend that's where the
power is sounding from talking to you
and knowing what
what like your skills and you being
connected to us
i'm like dude success will be inevitable
if you've done your research in the
financial independence thing
it's just a matter of making a decision
and being like let me just go all in on
this and i'm sure
you know about perseverance and grit and
the ups and downs of like if it doesn't
work out immediately
like nothing works out super fast and so
it's like thinking back and saying what
do i really want to happen
and if in three years i want to be at a
hundred thousand subscribers
with six figures of income coming in
because of the personal finance niche
like
i i would i think right now you could
just
go straight towards that target but you
will delay your journey in getting there
i think if you uh divide your energy
between multiple things i think that's a
good
unlock there the the concept of pausing
the other channel because what i
imagine is that i have to do one video
every week on my current channel as well
and then do the same on the new one as
well i didn't even consider the idea of
pausing the current channel that's a
that's a good idea actually you know do
you think that's going to hurt
the channel in any way with consistent
consistency being so important
i think that well of course it's gonna
hurt it
i mean it's not gonna keep growing at
the same level but i think
exactly what you said is what we all
struggle with our temptation
is okay i'm gonna do one a week but when
i start something new now i'm gonna do
one a week here and one a week there
oh and then you might start you know you
get another idea and and
that's the that's the inherent issue it
is
the sac like it's a mental battle
there's another channel i have
that i also still i was you know kind of
letting it just be on fumes
kind of a faith-based leadership channel
called think international that this is
10 years old
we were doing a lot of interviews with
people in like the non-profit
faith-based space
and it did well you know about 250
videos grew to
15 000 subscribers and if you look at
some of the most recent videos
even a few years back four years ago i i
posted this
four years ago i was doing some of these
episodes right here
and so so even like that's even four
years ago
that's crazy because that's like 2016
i had way too many things going on i was
fighting for my life
i just thought my freelance clients i
was like building think media i was
doing video influencers
i'm also what am i doing over here too
talking about church media i literally
was like
running four or five different projects
when i should have been running one and
i'm actually glad this theme is coming
up because i think a ton of people in
our community need to think about this
it's easy for ambitious entrepreneurial
people
to get a new idea that's a good idea
but then to think okay cool i'll start a
new channel and maybe if i just really
batch and i really get disciplined
then like i can keep posting one video a
week and if i look back
it's really looking getting uh serious
sitting now with the journal locking
yourself in a room and being like okay
what's like the one project i'm gonna
work on one of the reasons it took four
years to get youtube secrets out
is because i was spread so thin between
multiple different projects
i am like the master of over committing
to too many
like i like my greatest skill is
starting too many things at once
having too many things you know going on
it kind of reminds me of like uh my
stepdad phil and sonia's dad brad
they're like kind of your tinker fix the
car
garage you know i love to get off work
and like build stuff and like fix a
motorcycle type of a person
and the thing that you experience when
you walk into their garages though
is like a half-built engine like you
know
like an exhaust you know header that's
like set up over here
like some fishing pole that they're like
shaving down like fixing over here
you know switching up and like polishing
a shotgun over here
and and you're like finish a project you
know what i mean like
what if you started the engine rebuilt
the engine re-put
and and you have all these kind of open
projects and um man it's the this is the
power of
if you want the shortest path between
where you are and success in business
the shortest path is going to be
eliminating distractions eliminating
nonsense really the power of
focusing on really one thing
and and so that's what i would encourage
you know
here's maybe the sign in the clouds of
being on coffee with cannell
is i just showed you my personal channel
that's almost at 100 000
kind of as it just gets the residual of
building
one thing really big that how hard is it
going to be
me for to build a personal brand quickly
on sean cannell on the back end of when
we're at 2 million subscribers on think
media not difficult does that make sense
so your personal finance
financial freedom channel that you build
will
potentially not only get you to
profitability sooner
but it'll actually probably get you to
influence sooner and then
your personal first and last name
channel is something you could come back
to later a level of automation is there
you got some video editors hired you got
some other things happening
and so um that's what i think it is i
mean
again of course you can try and
fight the battle on two fronts but it's
too many of us are doing that
especially if you're editing all your
own videos you just added even more work
if you're having to come up with all the
content ideas you didn't just add more
physical exhaustion time
you're putting more creative exhaustion
and mental bandwidth
on yourself and we are not robots
some as entrepreneurs we think we are
sometimes we think we're invincible
but you want your best mental faculties
your best
creative energy to be devoted to
a project that's really going to make
make a difference so that's that's just
some hard one advice
through the acceleration of of my gray
hair
from doing 48 projects over the last 10
years
and looking back and thinking man if i
would have really just focused on
one thing at a time you may have heard
the quote that you could do
anything but you can't do everything
yeah that's the idea that literally as
humans we can do anything like do you
want to go learn jiu jitsu great
do you want to you know beat final
fantasy 7 remake
at the hardest level going back through
it whatever awesome
like we could do anything you wanna but
you just can't do everything because if
you're also going to be
the best fortnight player and great at
golf
and you know like travel to like you you
just can't do it
like everything but you can do anything
so what's the one thing you're going to
do
but i don't i think i just kind of
thought about this myself
when i heard that quote i was like yeah
but you can do anything
just not all at once so you also could
do
all the things one after another them
all at the same year don't do them all
in the same sequence of years so i was
like
man i'm only 36. like
man i could i could just build this
think media thing for the next
four years and then when i'm in my 40s i
could shift to leadership business
development content
there's a bunch of books i want to write
like 10 books right now i'm writing
notebooks right now because i'm focused
on team development
content creation course development like
so knowing what i'm focused on in terms
of think media
but then realizing like i can work on
some stuff
in two years you could do anything just
not everything you could do everything
just not everything all
at once and thinking about phases and
seasons
i wonder if that isn't really the best
advice because something like financial
independence that's going to be
interesting
also in two years or five years so maybe
one solution is to
to kind of build on the momentum that i
have on the first channel now
and then come back to that because
there's no there's no timely reason to
do financial independence right now i
find
there you go well hey marcus did you
guess the value today was this uh
a valuable conversation absolutely and
one thing i always like about you guys i
think is that i think you're the best at
sharing like your own mistakes like you
share so generously i think that's super
valuable for everybody watching
well i appreciate that marcus grateful
for you thanks so much for coming on the
show today
and uh keep crushing man excited to see
the journey of you growing your channel
take care my friends
you can do anything but you can't do
everything
but you can do everything just not
all at once do one thing at a time
get it done to completion
man the journey of getting this book
done learned a lot
we thought it takes six months took four
years
grateful that it came out right and not
rushed
but what i also realized is now that the
book's out
it's out and it compounds in momentum
it's
done it's completed it's not having a
half-built engine in your garage
and then like you're real you're
rebuilding some kind of hunting rifle
while you're also like sharpening your
fishing poles why are you sharpening
your fishing poles does it make sense
yeah you can see the outdoorsman in me
really knows what he's talking about um
but it's like get it done get it
going get something set up focus on it
focus on it to completion what's
completion mean
to where it's got some momentum where
it's systematized
where it's automated and when it comes
to youtube businesses
that's where you got you got like video
editing automated you've got a level of
a team in place maybe you've got a
virtual assistant
maybe you've got a system of creating
content at this point
one of the reasons why i could even
dream check this out
about really going into my sean cannell
channel is because if you've been
watching think media
you know that people are creating
content on that channel like nolan and
omar
and heather and tony ariola and so
there's other content creators there
we're building that
into being more of a bigger brand that's
the think media family and the think
media team
which gives me freedom to work on other
projects
but here's the kicker in light of that
i'm like i could work on sean cannell on
that right now
i could actually start another thing
but the wisdom and lessons and pain i've
learned over the last 10 years
is i'm not going to nope i'm gonna
double down on the one thing
think media what's think marketing an
extension of think media
it's our it's our marketing side of our
podcast and whatnot
and because of a team it's why it's
sustainable brick by brick
piece by piece if you're just starting
don't try and do what we're doing you
don't try and like
run a sick video podcast while by the
way posting five videos a week on think
media and you might know that but like
again
if you're comparing your beginning to
somebody else's middle
you're seeing maybe all the outputs
they're doing and you're putting too
much weight on yourself at the beginning
you'll burn out
you'll wear yourself out you gotta know
the season you're in and know
the shortest path to results the
shortest path to revenue
the shortest path to impact for the
season that you're
in um and then make those smart
moves hey we're going to bring kate on
the show
for a quick one kate i've got a meeting
coming up here in a second
uh hey tell me about your channel what's
your question where are you uh from
right now and uh how's life how's it
going
life is good um you and i i i'm so proud
of you sean i have watched you build
this i have been part of your community
for so long and just super super proud
of you
um kate bowman is my channel um i
was first doing a lot of stuff it's so
funny i was laughing at your
conversation around focus
i felt like i really wanted to get more
focused um
i run a company that's like what i do
for a living so i changed my focus on
doing more just like
personal development type stuff to
um book reviews like non-fiction book
reviews
and so i recently changed my channel to
do that
and um i just feel like i'm getting a
little bit frustrated
even though i literally just changed it
just changed it so
i don't know if i'm just like being
impatient or um
i was trying to figure out like
different versus videos to do
like i just want to i think i just need
um
i just wanted you to kind of look in at
the channel and see like if anything
stands out at you
things that i like could be doing
yep yep well first of all uh it's great
to see you i
uh having you on and seeing your channel
um
you've definitely been a part of the
community for a long time and so it's
good to see you doing well
um i love this book right of a lifetime
that was a great one
i want to read atomic habits and uh man
what should i read next
i'm turning it on you kate what should i
read
next oh well what do you want to learn
like that's the biggest thing
right right now it's what is your
biggest pain points what is the biggest
thing you want to develop in
probably um team building maybe um
scaling i want to read scale up
i'm reading the great game of business
um
yeah that's probably maybe okay i'm
gonna do 75 heart it starts this sunday
andy for sellers seventy five hard
heather taurus isaiah's doing it omar's
doing it
i wanted to actually just some personal
development mindset books
i've read a lot of the good ones i don't
mind re reading them because you're
supposed to read 10 pages a day and i
don't necessarily want to get super
tactical and like i kind of want to work
on like just confidence mindset
things like that so if you if you're
going to read scaling up
um traction is such a great book scaling
up is a lot
more like very textbooky traction is
more of a story
and that's a great place for you because
you're going to learn a lot about how to
scale
i mean you're already you've already
grown it right like you just have to
learn some of like
you learn a lot about like quarterly
rocks and all that kind of stuff
um you know one of the things that i
just read that i loved is joe
berger has a new book out i read
contagious but he has a new book
called um oh gosh i just forgot the name
of it
but that book is awesome for you because
it's all about how things
go viral so i think you'll learn some
you'll be you'll get some stuff that you
can actually share with your community
yeah yeah like the video side of things
which i think would be really awesome
atomic habits is a great book i mean i
feel like you're pretty good with your
habits
sean but yeah right well 75 hard
uh have you heard of that before yeah
yeah
and so i i mean 75 days no cheat days
you know two 45 minute workouts and a
baby on the way my wife's like what are
you even thinking
and i'm like i don't know are you
thinking jonah's contagious book why
things catch on
i loved that book and i also loved
you're really great at sharing stories
dan and chip heath
all their books are so good but the
power of moments
that book is so incredible and i feel
like for any leader
it's really good and especially on like
the customer service side
um i love how he talks about just like
the power of uh just the
how do you create better moments for
your family for
your life for your clients your
customers
um joey coleman has a great book too
called never lose a customer again
that one's good if you guys aren't i
need to read split the difference also
that book sean will change your life i
read it at least like i i've already
read it twice this year
and i think dang that's that's that that
gave me clarity because you reminded me
as i was thinking about you said
customers let's think about negotiation
yeah split the difference okay hey i i
gotta jump so i'm gonna do a rapid fire
fire thing here okay um okay my first
thought is a couple things success
leaves clues
if you wanna really crush in the book
arena i know this can be this might even
sound frustrating
it might sound like a limitation but if
we just assume that everything is on the
table in terms of
uh the opportunity for growth
first and foremost um you are getting
results you could
keep doing what you're doing but one of
the most powerful things to consider is
content formats
and i think recognizing that what
sometimes people want is they want book
summaries they want the drawn out book
summaries
and i know that might be like well shoot
who's going to draw them or like i don't
know if that's what i want to do
but what actually works on youtube um
if you actually are giving the book
summary it still could lead to a sale of
the book
i think it could also of course lead to
maybe like audible
um sign ups you know we've we generated
over 30 000
of youtube secrets audible people
signing up for free audible accounts
you know uh because of the five or ten
dollars so again
a lot of people may get the bulk of the
book
almost like a free leadership summary
subscription but you deliver that value
right on youtube and then it still leads
to the residual or whatever else
so the people that do the um the drawn
out books maybe
another way of doing a book summary and
you just deliver that book summary
deliver some of the key takeaways
and then give an invitation pointing to
the whole book um and then the other big
one though
is just is listicles like you know
um when i think about best books for
and if you could make that book
get attention you know like make the
video get attention hold people's
attention
organize them best books of all time
best books to read for knowledge
best books to read for self-development
um with how sharp you are with how much
you're really reading
i mean that would be more so than even
the individual search
of a particular book even like atomic
habits
best books you know for entrepreneurs
and what's crazy is it goes pretty deep
best marketing books for entrepreneurs
that's books that are black
entrepreneurs best books for beginner
entrepreneurs
so i think that those i mean i
best self-development books i don't know
if if i'm still up there
but uh i'm i got pushed down by a few
but here i am
uh this this did really well and i think
one of the big keys
that that made this this video do well
was hand picking books
watch this later because the structure
of it in terms
of teeing up why like what the books
meant why i chose them they weren't just
random kind of they were for seven
different
areas of life and not just
making it more substantive i think that
the way the video was structured
again led to quite a big growth here and
then
i've got the kit.co leading to a broken
link
awesome that's what coffee with canal is
forced to find where your links are
broken
but if it was uh let's see you just
gotta get rid of the m because
they lost kit.com so i'll fix that link
so then you can embed the video
and i've got the affiliate links to a
couple greats
in terms of self-development there so i
think that that
um just kind of at a snapshot is what i
would do if i was you maybe some other
formats
listicles for sure i wouldn't
necessarily
stop what you're doing because i think
it adds value and it has maybe a long
tail value
and if i was you i would also then
interview all the authors
i would work on getting every single one
of those offers authors i would start an
interview show
and um even now you probably get yeses
from a lot of them i think eventually
once momentum's there
you get them all and that is i'm sure
you would enjoy that
it leads to networking relationships it
of course leads to their influence
potentially but even without that i just
it's just personally something i love to
do because
uh you know getting a chance to kind of
ask them different questions and
whenever they launch a new book of
course they want to come on the show
that could turn into a podcast
um video podcast as well and um that's
just a few things i do
if um i was in your exact situation
right now
do you have i have my first one with an
author
next week so i totally was like going to
do that and then also what
do you have recommendations for versus
videos for me
um i don't know if too many people look
for that
yeah like they're not like do i read a
ton like
versus videos would be i mean what
versus videos for you would be kindle
versus the barnes noble one or like this
ipad versus that ipad the app
it would be though and those could lead
to because those are going to be readers
that would discover your channel
it's what people are actually asking
like you know i mean
it's not a writing channel but it'd be
like scrivener versus word for like
writing
you know things people search for in
verses is key not just verses for versus
sake
right i did audible versus scribd and
that
is one of my more highly ranked over the
past couple years there you go
which doesn't surprise me at all because
it's definitely
your me the versus strategy is so dang
powerful because
it meets people right there at it's it's
literally
your second most popular video right so
yeah it would be it'd be yeah that's
like software
platforms ways to consume books
yeah and i think it's interesting i
almost wonder you could even
like best podcasts because maybe there's
podcasts done by authors
and and different things that maybe i
think are
in the the right orbit of what you're
saying but then maybe
you know what just other thoughts like
that and
that listicles thing is a huge strategy
a couple of those could break out and
they lead into your
your world okay all right awesome thank
you sean i appreciate it
i appreciate you kate thanks so much for
coming on the show and uh keep crushing
it and thanks for the book tips
never split the difference that's the
next one for me
love it get it all right take care
all right my friends coffee with kennel
did you get value today hit the like
button thanks to
everybody uh for of course hanging out
in the back end of the show
excited for the next episode uh merlin
would love to have you on joseph
amit brendan david i'm a little bit late
right now for a meeting and so
uh i'm gonna jump here but um
i appreciate you grateful for you we'll
do our best to advertise out the next
coffee with cannell i want to encourage
you come on the think marketing q a as
well
uh we'll talk about your marketing your
landing pages your email marketing your
branding your positioning your youtube
strategy
with heather taurus and melissa caputo
once a week coffee with kennel
once a week to think marketing q a um
and
if you're ready to jump into the next
thing
of course check out the think master
class that we've done
thinkmasterclass.com and
if you want to get to that a thousand
subscribers get some strategies
that are working right now to trigger
the youtube algorithm get your videos to
show up in suggested
videos go to thinkmasterclass.com and
you can watch
basically a free session from our video
ranking academy coaching program
entirely for free and uh that's at
thinkmasterclass.com link in the
description below
i appreciate you keep crushing it keep
smashing it
keep killing it and we're here come on
helping you
with the best tips with the best tools
for building your influence with online
video i will see you in the